favorite castle george favorite castle
uh-huh um
let me see i do i'm very fond of my
castles
uh and of course winterfell is where it
all began
so that's that's probably going to be
the choice
winterfell and what would you have based
winter fell on did you have a
real world castle in your head when you
thought about that one
not directly no no i
it's a it's a fairly simple castle it's
most distinctive feature is
the double the double wall with the moat
between
which uh i've never seen a real castle
that has that particular architectural
uh
feature but uh um
but i like the size of it and the
godswood in the center of it
and uh you know it's really more of a
town my castles are
bigger than most real world castles by
and large
especially because they go down as well
yes yes
i'm also very fond of of a pike on the
iron islands
which was actually based on a couple of
scottish castles but the idea of a
of a castle that's on these sea stacks
that uh you know
very inaccessible and linked only by
these bridges and and so forth
it would be a miserable place to live it
would be cold and
damp and wet but it produces a lot of
explains a lot about the personality of
the ironborn
[Laughter]
i do actually like caves you know um
i've i've i live in new mexico we have
crossbad caverns one of the great
great cave systems in the world i just
visited there again
uh last year on the way to worldcon
and uh i've been there
you know a dozen times over the years
and i've been to other caves when i
travel
and they're endlessly fascinating uh
and if i was you know 30 years younger
and in much better physical condition
of all the sports i would love to uh be
a caver or
explorer i mean it's it's
it's the last true realm of exploration
on on the planet earth it's
it's the only place that at least a
theoretical possibility
exists that you could crawl through a
hole and go to a place that no other
human being has ever stood
no has ever seen and you know the light
of your lantern could be the first light
that's ever fallen in this secret place
below the earth
and uh you know that's
i don't know i find that tremendously
exciting but uh
it is probably it can i know your eugene
are a rock climber
who clamors to the top of of mountains
and it might be somewhat the same appeal
like the opposite
yeah because i i'm very claustrophobic
i do not like enclosed spaces and i'm
well known when i'm climbing
never to get into cracks or chimneys i
will always do something
far more difficult up the front face of
something
i on the other hand do not like falling
off mountains
well i love that
[Laughter]
we did talk about climbing when you were
doing your scene for the
when they went up the wall that's right
jane
jane was my uh my technical resource
when uh
for the the climb uh when jon snow and
the wildlings had to go up that uh 700
feet of ice wall or
what that would be like i mean that with
medieval climbing equipment
hard yeah do you remember the first
story you ever wrote george the first
story i ever wrote ever
um yeah
it was i never finished any of my early
stories what i wrote as a kid they they
were
they're all beginnings
editors
there were there were these uh
space man toys aliens that were sold in
five and dime shops in new jersey when i
was a kid
i'm as an adult i collect toys and uh
and figurines and i become somewhat uh
knowledgeable about this so i now know
from the vantage point of a collector
that these were
aliens made by a company called miller
and they're generally referred to as the
miller aliens
uh they were produced in the 1950s and
sold through kresge's and woolworths and
similar stores
in large bins for 15 cents each they
were made of extruded plastic which was
this kind of waxy cheap plastic that
like broke if you looked at it crooked
and couldn't be glued back together to
my great frustration
so they were very fragile things but
they were great aliens they they all had
what planet they came from on the base
and they were weird looking
there was a snake guy and there was a
like a giant beetle guy who had
like eight legs and two of them had ray
guns of different designs and there was
a
two-headed robot and uh there were all
that so i got the whole set
you know and some were hard to get
because the beetle guy and the snake guy
were always breaking and you'd go
through the bins and
oh all the beetle guys are broken again
but you know when i finally got an
attack beetle guy uh and i
made up stories about them i decided who
were all these guys
it had what planet they came from but
they didn't have names so i invented
names for all of them
and i decided the martian guy who had he
was green he had a big green head he was
holding a little
rocket ship he was the head his name was
john and he was there
they were space pirates and he was the
captain and the mastermind because he
had a big head he must be smart
and uh you know and i invented all sorts
there was one little guy from orion
he was yellow and he was holding this
weird sort of weapon the toy was
it looked like a drill so i decided he
was the torturer
so even even as a little kid i was
thinking of torture
but they had all sorts of great
adventures john and his space pirates
and
uh um those were the first stories i
wrote
did you share them with anybody else no
they were just for me
just for me printed out in my big chief
tablets and
and uh you know my my hand
when did you sell your first
professional story what was the first
thing you sold
um for me it was uh a story called the
hero
which i sowed to galaxy i sold it in the
summer of
that 1970 and it appeared in uh i
believe the february 71 issue
wow of galaxy magazine
i had actually written it several years
earlier
[Music]
you know when i was in college i went to
northwestern university
just north of chicago and i was a
journalism major so i was writing a lot
uh for journalism courses but i wanted
to write short stories
and fiction and i would take creative
writing courses
and write it for that but i was also
always looking for an opportunity to uh
to write short stories for other courses
[Music]
i remember once i took a lot of history
courses and i would frequently ask my
history professors if i could write a
historical fiction for the instead of a
term paper and uh
some of them actually said yes so it was
actually a course in scandinavian
history
that i was taking and the professor said
yes and i wrote a story about
the russia finnish war of 1808
the surrender of the great fortress of
sveaboard
you know a great mystery in finnish
history
and the professor liked it so well that
not only did he give me an a but he sent
it off to
a professional magazine so that was
where i got my first projection slip
uh but it was very nice rejection slip
it was you know it was uh
the editor said very nice things and
said well we don't publish
fiction but if we did we might like to
use this story because it's good
so i said hey this sending out stories
and getting rejected slips isn't as
painful as i thought it would be so i'll
i'll try it and i took some of the
stories that i had written
for uh creative writing courses uh some
science fiction some non
and started sending them out to
magazines and one of them was uh the
hero
and it did it got a number of rejection
slips but eventually it stole
wow do you remember how much you got
paid for it
ninety four dollars okay how much left
ninety four dollars a lot of money in
those days man
it was 1970 you could you could uh go to
town from ninety four dollars it was
boy i had 94 dollars in my bank account
i was pretty excited
did you go to town what did you spend it
on what did i what
what did you spend it on uh
i don't remember offhand but uh you know
beer
probably figured into it somewhere